foreign
um could I just first of all
um warmly welcome you also the president
of the commissioner president vondeline
to Dublin as we Mark 50 years of our
transformative membership of the
European Union and we look forward uh to
discussing with ursulin the many
challenges that the European Union faces
and our commitment to finding shared
Solutions I want to pay tribute to the
leadership of the president
um over the last number of years
particularly during the pandemic the war
on Ukraine and managing the energy
crisis that has resulted from that we
will discuss today how we can continue
to make real or unequivocal support for
the people of Ukraine as they face into
a very cold and difficult
um winter and face the ravages of a
terrible immoral and illegal war and of
course we will discuss the energy crisis
the slowing global economy but above all
knowing the president's strong
commitment to intensifying the green
transition we will discuss that um also
and of course
our relationship with like-minded
countries like the United States and the
United Kingdom we will discuss the
ongoing situation in terms of the
Northern Ireland the protocol we
appreciate the solidarity that has been
shown but of course we all want to have
a constructive and solid relationship
with our neighbors the United Kingdom so
that will form the basis of our
discussions today as we Mark 50 years of
Ireland's transformative membership of
the European Union
thank you very much t-shock martindia
Michal
um first of all thank you very much for
inviting me it's such a pleasure such an
honor and I want to personally thank you
for the excellent cooperation we had in
the last two and a half years
these were very eventful years indeed as
you said first of all the pandemic
you have steered very skillfully Ireland
through the pandemic and out of the
pandemic and I highly appreciate how
you've always been a strong supporter of
our vaccine strategy
um and you have presented an excellent
National Recovery and resilience plan
under Next Generation EU where I had the
honor and the pleasure to be here to
present it together with you
now indeed we are in difficult times
because Russia Unleashed an atrocious
war against Ukraine
and first and foremost I want to thank
the Irish people
for opening their hearts and their homes
to Ukrainian Refugee this is outstanding
and I want to thank you for the strong
support for Ukraine to become a
candidate member of the European Union
of course all of us are feeling the
knock-on effects of this atrocious War
um for example the high energy price
environment
and here indeed we're working very
closely together first of all to
diversify away from Russian fossil fuels
with success
we have saved a lot of energy we have
filled our storages so we are safe for
the winter but of course there needs to
be also an answer for the minute long
term and here I want to underline how
impressive the Irish investment in
renewable energy is so you are now best
your best way to become a clean energy
superpower in the European Union
finally on brexit
indeed we have always had a very close
cooperation it was Ironclad and is
Ironclad and this is so important
I know that brexit meant a lot of
adaptation for Ireland but you have done
this very successfully as far as I can
see it
we the European Union have been
listening very carefully to the concerns
of people and businesses in Northern
Ireland what the issues of the protocol
is concerned
um and we have always shown flexibility
we will always have a constructive
approach to these issues if there is the
political will in the UK I am very
confident that we can reach a positive
conclusion so thank you very much for
inviting me and I'm looking forward to
this day here in Ireland
thank you very much indeed thank you
can you see it now
on the steps okay yeah